صفعه ويل سميث في الاوسكار العام الماضي
يبدو انها ما زالت تدوي وقد تكون غيرت
مسار الحفل الى الابد في الحفل الذي سيقام
بعد اسبوعين تقريبا عينت اكاديميه لاول
مره فريق ازمه سيكون جاهزا للتدخل ومنع اي
سلوك يمكن ان يعكر من صفو الحفل وصورته
الصفعه الشهيره كانت رد فعل من ويل سميث
بعدما اطلق كريس روك مقدم الحفل مسحه يشير
فيها لراس جاد سميث الحليق بعد تشخيصها
بداء الثعلبه
على جائزه الاوسكار لاول مره لكن الفضيحه
كان لها صدى عالمي احرجت اللجنه المنظمه
وحذر بسببها سميث من حضور اي فعاليه تتعلق
بالمهرجان لمده عشر سنوات
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
على فكره في مارس من عام الماضي كانت صفحه
ويل سميث في حفل الاوسكار حدثا عالمي حتى
غطى على احداث الحرب في اوكرانيا
الاغلب رفض سلوك العدواني فيما اخرون
كانوا يعتقدون النصف مثل يستحق العقاب لكن
الحظر لمده عشر سنوات من حضور فعاليات
اوسكار كانه كان مبالغ فيه انت كيف شفتي
الصفعه الشهيره متواضع هاي الصفعه ما فيني
اعلق لانه انا من الناس اللي بتحبو كثيرا
بس سلوكه كان غلط في حفل الاوسكار يعني
مرات كمان انه في ناس بيضطروك لرده فعل
يعني انا مثلا دائما بشوف انه حتى بالحياه
بيجوا بيحاسبوا الانسان على رده فعله
فبساله يا جماعه شو صار قبل لاوصل الانسان
لهون نظريات المؤامره ايضا في الصوره
اعتقد كثيرون ان الصفحه اصلا كانت
بالاتفاق مع كريستيروك واللجنه لرفع
مشاهدات حفل
وخاصه تم كثير الاعلان عن تراجع عدد
مشاهدي المهرجانات بشكل ملحوظ خلال
السنوات الماضيه ففي مشكله جديده بدات
تنضم الينا بشكل ملحوظ في السنوات الماضيه
ممكن يعني عشر سنين تقيله عشر سنين انه
يحرموه من حضور حفل اوسكار مده طويله من
القاهره رحاب هاني استاذ مساعد بكليه
الاعلام بجامعات القاهره رحاب يسعد صباحك
المره الاولى في حفل اوسكار يتم تشكيل
خليه او فريق ازمات توقعا لاي احداث غير
متوقعه في الاوسكار كصفات اولا هل كان ذلك
متوقع
صباح الخير اولا
كان متوقع الحقيقه وكان ضروري انه انه
يحصل الموضوع دوت لانه طبعا الازمه
الكبيره زي ما حضراتكم قلتم في البدايه في
المقدمه بخصوص الصفعه كانت في الحقيقه
اساءه كبيره للاكاديميه لانه بعيدا عن
السبب وانا كنت سامعه نقاشكو يعني في
الحقيقه الفعل نفسه كان مفاجئ جدا
والحقيقه غير مقبول لانه ما ينفعش انه
كوميديان يقول
زي ما بيقولوا افيه او يقول
موز حمام فيكون رد الفعل تجاهله بهذا
العنف احنا ممكن نحاسبه ممكن نتكلم معاه
ممكن نتناقش لكن بالتاكيد ما كانش هذا
الرد المبالغ فيه اللي في الحقيقه كتير من
الحضور كانوا فاكرين ان هو متفق عليه يعني
حتى نظره لوبيتانيونغ قاعده جنب ويل سميث
كانت بصله ان هي مش فاهمه اذا كان ده
مترتب ولا كان حقيقي لحد لما طبعا الكل
ادرك انه حقيقي فكان من المطلوب جدا خاصه
ان الاكاديميه مش او الاسكريز يعني مش مش
غريبه على المواقف الغريبه انه يكون عندها
فريق لحل الازمات سريعا طيب دكتوره رحاب
هل للتعب نجوم الاوسكار من كريستيروك
والسميث
عنده الشجاعه
الرهيبه يعني هو السؤال اللي كان متداول
بعد الحفل هو ايه اللي مر بيه عشان يوصل
للمرحله دي لانه في الحقيقه كان في ضغوطات
كتيره جدا جدا ومواقف كتيره جدا جدا تعرض
ليها كتير من النجوم في كثير من المواقف
يعني في 2017 وده موقف يمكن يكون مختلف تم
الاعلان عن فوز فيلم مختلف تماما بجائزه
احسن فيلم في الاوسكيرز كان لالا لاند
وكان الفيلم الفايز هو في الحقيقه مون
لايت وكانت تعتبر يعني على حد وصف البعض
ان هي فضيحه لانه احنا قلنا اسم فيلم
مختلف تماما عن الفيلم الحقيقي اللي فاز
بس تم يعني
تداول موضوع اكثر بشكل الطف لانه وجود
جيمي كامل اللي كان وقتها الهوست واللي في
الحقيقه هيرجع ثاني ان هو يكون هوست
الحفله السنه دي في مارس باذن الله طيب
خلقت دكتوره حلا عالميه لكن الملفت هذه
الحاله العلميه العالميه تتراجع بالنسبه
لحفلاتك الاوسكار والجولدن جلوب لماذا لم
تعد تحظى بنفس الاهتمام كما في السابق
في الحياه اعتقد انه الفتره الخاصه
بالجائحه تحديدا وبكرونه
وكل التغييرات اللي حصلت سواء في التنظيم
وفي شكل الحفل خلى في حاله من فقدان
الحماسه تجاه الحفلات دي خاصه انها فقدت
كتير من رونقها للاسف الشديد كحد محب جدا
للسينما ومتابع يعني دقيق للحفلات كلها
الخاصه بالجوائز فيمكن ده كان جزء كبير
جدا لانه الوتيره الخاصه بمتابعه تلك
الحفلات والمهرجانات كانت اكبر بكثير من
بعد او من قبل كورونا عن بعد كورونا طيب
اليوم دكتوره رحاب
ما حجم القدره على التعامل مع اي مفاجات
محتمله في الحفل المقبل نتحدث عن مارس
المقبل بعد المفاجاه بصفعه سميث
وتداعياتها وهذه البلبله التي حصلت بعدها
في الحقيقه هو فريق الازمات ده كان زي ما
قلنا فريق مهم جدا واظن ان هو مستعد بشكل
من الاشكال لان الاكاديميه برضو تعرضت
مؤخرا لموقف يعتبر موقف حساس وهو خاصه بعد
ترشيح الممثله
اللي هي الممثله البريطانيه عن فيلم
تولزلي لجائزه احسن ممثله وده كان ترشيح
غير متوقع خاصه وان الاكاديميه عندها يعني
قواعد معينه فيما يتعلق او التسويق الخاص
بالافلام فكان الفيلم بتاعها يعتبر فيلم
مستقل ولم يحظي بقدر كبير من التسويق ولكن
هي حظيت بقدر كبير من الدعم من نجوم فوهلي
واد وغيرهم
فاتشاف انه في شكل من الاشكال زي ما يكون
انه احنا دفعنا بها دفع او كان في ضغط على
الاكاديميه وتم الترشيح ففريق الازمات على
طول بعدها طلع بعد وقت طلع تصريح او طلع
بيان طبعا من الاكاديميه بخصوص فكره
ترشيحها وانه المسيح بتاعها كان ترشيح
سليم وما كانش فيه اي نوع من انواع
الضغوطات او غيره فده كان مثال ومثال قريب
جدا لكيفيه تعامل فريق الازمات مع المواقف
اللي ممكن يتعرضوا لها ونتمنى انه ما
يبقاش فيه مفاجات زي مفاجاه ويل سميث
السنه دي علشان كانت مفاجاه عنيفه شويه
الله يهدي النفوس شكرا جزيلا لك من
القاهره الدكتوره رحاب هاني استاذ مساعد
بكليه الاعلام في جامعه القاهره